Stranger Things 2 has officially arrived and
has introduced two new kids to the Hawkins,
Indiana crew.
Billy and Max are step-siblings who've moved
from California with their parents and couldn't
be more different from one another.
Billy is a loose cannon who behaves like a
bully and desperately wants to dethrone Steve
as the coolest kid in school.
Meanwhile Max is a skateboarding tomboy who
proves to be a wizard at Dig Dug and catches
the attention of Dustin and Lucas just as
they prepare to face a new threat from the
upside-down.
The actors portraying the Stranger Things
2 duo, Dacre Montgomery and Sadie Sink, are
still relatively new to show-business as well.
But you still may recognize them from some
of these other productions...
The comedy club
Not long before the release of Stranger Things
2, Australia native Dacre Montgomery's career
started gaining traction with a small role
in the 2016 Australian-American horror comedy
Better Watch Out — a critically acclaimed,
over-the-top film chock full of teenage talent.
The film is basically a deadlier version of
Home Alone, and let's just say that Montgomery's
character gets in over his head.
Soon after, Montgomery also starred as Mike
in A Few Less Men — a direct sequel to the
critically panned Australian-British comedy
A Few Best Men — before earning the role
that would transform his career altogether.
Morphin' time
Dacre Montgomery's biggest pre-Stranger Things
role is unquestionably that of Red Ranger
Jason Scott, the leader of the titular superheroes
in the Power Rangers reboot.
Although he earned the lead in the pic, he'd
never seen the show or films that started
it all before auditioning.
He told The Hollywood Reporter, "I'd love
to blame that I was on the west coast [of
Australia], in the most isolated city on the
planet, but I think Power Rangers really had
reached every corner of the earth, so I don't
know, I just missed it!"
Even so, he had no trouble adapting to all
the mighty morphin' that went down on the
set and even delivered the film's most iconic
line.
"It's morphin' time."
On Broadway
Sadie Sink started acting professionally at
10 years old, after an obsession with 2006's
High School Musical inspired her to pursue
drama in a rural Texas community theatre.
Eventually, she earned the title role in the
2012 Broadway revival of Annie, which is when
the ball really started rolling on her young
career.
It was also then that she first met Stranger
Things' Caleb McLaughlin and Gaten Matarazzo,
who were starring in The Lion King and Les
Miserables at the time.
As she told Vogue, "If you're a child, and
you're on Broadway, you automatically know
every other child in a production.
It's a proper community.
There's a park on 43rd Street where we would
all go to let off energy before we had to
go back and perform another show."
Though Annie was her biggest Broadway gig,
Sink also starred alongside veteran Helen
Mirren in 2015's The Audience.
TV turn
While hitting it big on Broadway, Sink made
her television debut in 2013 as a guest star
on FX's hit series The Americans.
She'd later pop up in other hit series such
as Blue Bloods and The Unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt.
Of course, Sink didn't merely make cameos.
Before landing the role of Max on Stranger
Things' second season, the young actress was
notably featured as a main cast member on
the NBC thriller American Odyssey.
Breaking into the big screen
Sadie Sink made her big-screen debut in 2016's
sports drama Chuck, in which she plays the
title character's daughter, Kimberly.
The boxing biopic received generally positive
reviews, and — though her role was minimal
— helped bolster the young star's résumé.
Her most prominent big-screen role to date
is that of a young Lori Walls in the 2017
American biographical drama The Glass Castle.
Based on Jeannette Walls' 2005 memoir of the
same name, the film follows an autobiographical
account of the author's poverty-stricken childhood
existence with her family and father.
While the film has received mixed reviews,
it certainly proved that Sink has just as
much talent on a film set as she does on a
small screen series.
As Stranger Things 2 escalates their public
profile, count on Dacre Montgomery and Sadie
Sink to continue accelerating their already
prolific screen careers.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!